house ago it got wanna burn my welcome
back to centre the arrival but have one
note left to catch and it's right
[ __ ] hair and I got it
what you gonna do what what you're gonna
do
[ __ ] where the hell did he go
out in the heavens no I was right that I
better but I'm running into it what are
you doing woman OH
yeah
what is going on okay Oh Tana thank God
oh no not the toddler all right that was
really weird how we all the sudden got
to the eight pages I don't get bad I
understand the decision ah it turns out
I was knocked out by the car accident
is that it no no I was just having a nap
by these rocks yep yep that makes sense
oh no my life or my battery is half now
[ __ ] bros I mean we've been [ __ ] a lot
of times before but this is a whole new
level of getting [ __ ] oh there's a
house there let's go there morning jog
sounds more like I'm jerking Dex
okay I'm that what that's not
appropriate
okay hello why does this prove hello
you're watching me aren't you mother
[ __ ] what's going on over here
whoa no whywhy the dramatic effect um I
like the mountains it's pretty this one
point da da da da la don't think I
forgot about you [ __ ]
whoa we're going in here
canola man I don't wanna all employers
after closing this Sunday your paycheck
will be mailed cool cool man mining is
that what it is that's actually kind of
curious current goal explore the area
yay
I'm sure this will go [ __ ] splendid
barrels everywhere goddamnit Bros we're
[ __ ]
hmm cold man is behind me oh [ __ ] what
am i even
oh this is door here hello Alice that's
cool man mining all employers must be
removed from the mines by emergency
lifts as soon as possible the power of
the lace please activate the emergency
generators through the ground level of
complex 6 generator minimum required to
power please see your supervisor and the
new supervisor yep
that's me I like the logic of this game
it's like your foot
we're followed by Slenderman hey let's
go in this creepy minds yeah why not
nothing really yeah local park sells
land - cool man mining couldn't be
happier he's glad the deal has gone
through ha ha what arrows did Slendy
draw this for me Thank You Slendy Oh
more arrows okay thank you thank you sir
up Moreira mora there's one other
generators all this activity need to get
to court
yeah
what the [ __ ] come down generators this
place is bigger than my yeah okay I got
one generator that's good right ha ha ha
I'm gonna forget [ __ ] in here I know
it but that's ok sometimes it's just
nice to spread your legs and you know
okay it's only him
what hello why do I hear footsteps over
there Oh
take that's quite she [ __ ] took me
virginity
[ __ ] this game I'm done I'm safe playing
okay
that's good don't you dare do that [ __ ]
again
ah Yolo
ah no please no please
no I do not want to get [ __ ] no place
thank you very much
that means I love you long time well
that mean I have two generators I don't
like this frittatas why would anyone
like this shut up music just shut your
[ __ ] mouth Jace
ah man donde esta su genera Torres
Shariati ah yes yes you [ __ ] barrel
oh oh oh okay
Oh three out of seconds I have time
diopside I'm sorry I'm sorry
we got to finish it up there later okay
I'll remember that I can run I can move
I sleep at night without Bros retry
retry like it's a [ __ ] easy thing to
do
[ __ ] I got three how the [ __ ] in the
Ducks face imma gonna get sex she's so
fat
I don't want to set the world on fire
by just want that's not here anymore the
generator [ __ ] me
I just want to start a flame in your
heart in my heart I have but 1d Zion
and that what is you know singing
soothes me okay begone spawn of Satan oh
she's scared of the light
Oh what you gonna do huh oh you scared
of a little light huh you little pest
got that [ __ ] no no I will not have
your [ __ ]
no big ah I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
no why did I don't I - it's no [ __ ]
generator in the toilet you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh no I know it's a no-no is
that no one what is it you don't
understand
odd Oh generator four out of six
I just want to piss no no as a No what
nomnom don't make me come over there and
get to the tower get to the chopper I'd
say get the [ __ ] out of here
no [ __ ] women never understand when I
say no god damn it god [ __ ] damn it
now 1945 yeah hey hey
I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going
I'm going
I know nobody's no one I'm wearing on
the pads I got damage what do you want
you want me to Yolo is that it
it's that [ __ ] what are you doing
there now huh that doesn't even stop
stop
Yolo I'll [ __ ] twist my nut ball and
going in there don't even know why I
tell you why cuz you can't sit aside
adiyogi lie they never fight a fuss they
never cut a cut then just stand on the
side and say a runner
I got an older boy and everybody bear
I'll get [ __ ] in the ass for one more
time
ain't nothing to it I just go ahead and
do it why the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] I will
find these generator no fun wait for
date any Luffy da quit all day if he
done no [ __ ] never [ __ ] listen man
no no no no no no [ __ ] no [ __ ] be
crazy man but just be [ __ ] crazy what
the [ __ ] I need two more generators I
can't even find [ __ ] one generator no
no no no no
oh no no I'm going here because this
looks kind of creepy
I'll shut that [ __ ] is coming no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no it's a dead end
oh hey okay we're [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no no no no no no no no
oh no no no
no no
what do i do what do i do what do i do
what do i go what do i do I do it
good yes oh yes yes I'm a lad as you
know sir what am I supposed to do
if I had a duck I would name him Luis
yes I would because what oh you [ __ ]
stop following me
nobody perfect you love it
stop ma I gotta stop does that woman not
get oh boom Shaq in the back from a
cracker I have five Jenner right that's
what you gonna do what you gonna do $5
okay we're not going that way
night-night if we find ya ha pod well he
had that this job